-It seems like there's so much
going on right now.
Prince Harry's new book
came out today.
The horror movie "M3GAN"
is a hit at the box office.
[ Laughter ]
Tonight's Mega Millions jackpot
was over $1.1 billion.
And Papa Johns just unveiled
these new doughy snack balls
called Papa Bites.
[ Laughter ]
There's lot to go over,
so let's just jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for a "News Smash."
♪♪
First up, Prince Harry.
Today, his new book called
"SPARE" hit shelves
and it's full of details about
his life, his relationships
and the exit from
the Royal Family.
Long story short, everything
changed when he married...
"M3GAN."
The --
[ Laughter ]
The horror movie is doing great
at the box office,
bringing in
over $30 million.
It's made so much money
the producers feel like
they won...
the lottery.
Tonight's Mega Millions jackpot
was one of the biggest
of all-time, over $1.1 billion.
Wow. That's a lot of...
dough.
Papa John's uses it
to make their new snack
called Papa Bites,
but don't eat too many,
you only have one heart.
You don't have a... "SPARE."
The book talks about how Harry
didn't get along with his
brother, his stepmother,
or his...
Papa.
Seriously, don't overdo it
on those little bites.
They're so high in calories
they could....
kill you.
"M3GAN" is a terrifying doll,
kinda like Annebelle
or even Chucky, the...
redhead.
Harry didn't have just one
reason to leave England,
it was more like...
$1 billion.
And that's -- that's enough
money to live like a...
prince.
Harry is speaking out against
his powerful family.
And you've got to admit,
that takes... balls.
These treats might be
too much for some people,
but stoners are looking
at them like...
jackpot!
In conclusion...
so much to tell.
Will it sell?
What's that smell?
Run like hell.
This has been a "News Smash."
♪♪